Time magazine announced its Person of
the Year today and it is not President
Trump yeah when when asked for comment
the White House said Shh we haven't told
him yet he's gonna get mad yeah it's
gonna get real I think they just don't
tell him a lot of their busy made
drawing a fake cover right yeah right
yeah it's you yeah
they put my face on a Newsweek and said
it with him in an interview Senate
candidate Roy Moore spokesperson said
his accusers gave Academy Award
performances
yeah then more interrupted and said I
just wish they'd been Teen Choice Awards
[Applause]
keep in mind there are fires out there
okay
whatever you think of these jokes I
think these at least were safe okay
that's what I'm leaning on tonight
amazon has now made it possible for you
to create a shopping profile for your
pet pretty cool huh
in fact today Vladimir Putin created one
for Donald Trump so
[Applause]
this morning Vladimir Putin speaking of
lerma Putin this morning Vladimir Putin
announced he's going to run for
re-election yeah then this afternoon he
announced he'd won things worked out
well he'd go in the ballot box and
there's a guy with a gun you like it
okay
president Trump's border wall prototypes
the test for the border wall are being
tested this week to see if they can be
climbed broken through or gotten around
yes spoiler alert they can Oprah gave
interesting interview Oprah recently
revealed that when she had a guess on
her show that was boring her go-to word
was WOW he imagined that Andy Wow
[Music]
that was a little play we just did no it
really was
you